In this lesson, we're going to take a look at the tools for merging geometry in Unreal.
So let's get started.
You'll see here there are several options to choose from.
Now, I'll go through in Unreal and show you how to work with this, etc.
It's pretty straightforward, but I'm first going to walk you through some of the different
options you have.
Now, they have an option for merge.
This merges and simplifies a mesh.
It merges materials and it banks details into normal map and each proxy LOD is one draw
call.
So what it does, it allows you to have not multiple draw calls on multiple pieces, but
makes one draw call as it combines the mesh into one piece, which is actually pretty convenient.
You'll notice here though in the menu settings that material is grayed out.
This actually makes a hybrid material, especially if you have two different materials already
existing and you combine those objects.
Now be careful when doing that if you decide to use this merge option, because if you have
multiple pieces with multiple different materials, it can be a little rough.
And when you decide to migrate this particular object, the material may not come along for
the ride and may require to be reconnected and rebuilt.
So that's a disadvantage with this.
So when you do use the merge tool, make sure it's just a couple of different materials
and not five or 10 different ones, because that's where things can get a little bit rough.
The next option we have is simplify.
This merges and simplifies the mesh also.
It merges materials, but you can control resolution.
So it tries to give you a nice resolution control so you can dumb it down as you need.
And it bakes details into the normal map and each proxy LOD is one draw call.
So that one's pretty beneficial.
There's also the old school batch method.
Now this one isn't used as much.
It tries to create like a nice instance reference for the combined object, which really isn't
needed.
This one I don't use so much.
It is a older reference tool, but we do have today a new way to be able to merge such
complicated meshes as a nanite and that's using approximate.
Proximate works really well.
It allows you to grab these higher visual fidelity, higher poly counted objects and
merge them with a little bit of better ease.
And you'll see there's several different options to choose from.
And we'll talk about these.
So we're going to get ready to jump into Unreal and take a closer look.
But before we do, I want to point out exactly how beneficial these tools are.
You'll see that these objects are merged.
The cliff.
You'll see like there's a pillar.
There's an archway.
That is one draw call because we merge them.
These over here that aren't merged with all the little details is 70 plus draw calls.
That again is a disadvantage.
So we're optimizing when we do this and making it lighter for the scene overall.
Now let's go ahead and jump into Unreal.
We can see in the case of this probe that there's a lot of detail and a lot of individual
parts in here.
Each one of these are a draw call, which could be to our disadvantage, especially if you
want to put a lot in the scene.
We see up here we have one that has already been merged.
And let me hit the F key.
You can actually see a downgrade of the resolution and the geometry silhouette in here.
But it's so far away from the camera, no one is really going to notice.
And that's to our advantage.
And you'll see that there's a hybrid material if you double click on it, which is a combination
of the normal maps and the texture all into one.
So Unreal tries to do that work for you.
So you don't have to worry about that as much.
But you'll notice again, this is for an object in the distance.
You'll see that the silhouette may break down a bit compared to our original down below,
which has a lot more visual fidelity to it and texture resolution.
But that's just one way to merge.
Let's look at them up close.
So go to our tools here, and we're going to go to merge actors.
I'm going to pull that up.
I'm going to pull this over to the side.
Now this is the basic merge.
Here's the settings.
You'll notice again, we don't have any material options.
So we can't control our overall resolution.
You'll see there's a thing called a gutter in Texels to add to each sub chart for our
baked out material for the top of MIP level.
So you can actually choose that.
The default relatively works great.
There's also baked vertex data to the mesh.
So if you did paint some vertices, some vertex information in there, you can actually bake
it to it.
And we also have Nanite settings if you were to work with Nanite on this particular object.
Now this guy hasn't been converted, and we do have that option.
But for really heavier pieces of geometry, I recommend you use approximate.
We'll look at that in just a second.
All right.
So let's go ahead and grab this piece of geometry.
And we're going to pick on this particular one, because I think he's pretty close to
the original.
And we're going to go ahead and find all the pieces to him.
Let's go and do that.
I'm going to Alt Control here, select him, make sure I don't have anything selected in
the background on accident.
There we go.
And we're going to go ahead and run a merge.
Now you can replace the actor if you want to, or pull the actor in.
This is really up to you.
But keep in mind, if you replace it, and it isn't what you want, you may not like that
one very well.
If you decide to pull it in, the pivot may be off, and you'll have to adjust it using
again some of the modeling tools that I showed you, which can be pretty helpful.
In this case, we're going to replace the actor, and we're going to merge actors.
It's going to ask you where to put it.
So just pick a nice little place to put it.
In our case, we can just simply load them into maybe a new folder here that we can just
call class.
And let's make one in class merge.
And open it up and save it there.
Now it's going to run and compress and make a new system honoring, you'll see two different
materials.
Now we didn't have any choice in resolution, but it went and combined, or I shouldn't say
combined.
My bad.
It went, it goes and honors the materials, and it makes two different sets in here for
us to look at.
Now that's actually pretty nice because there's less of a chance maybe of getting some deprecation
going on.
But we now have one particular, we have one object with one single draw call, which is
to our advantage.
But if we were going to go over here and say we wanted to make it so it isn't two materials
because each one of these are draw calls, we can actually do the next one, which was
the one we ran here with the F key.
And let's open up those emerge tools again.
And we had run simplify.
Now simplify again, we'll take that material, simplify the material as well as combine the
geometry, making one draw call.
Unfortunately, you will get hit on some of your silhouette items here.
There is a light map resolution if you were to use baking so you can actually get that
set up ahead of time.
We're not using that in this particular case.
You will also see a nanite section here.
You'll notice it's not enabled.
So we're okay in that front.
But if I was to have it enabled, I would want to make sure that I control such things as
positioning and normal precision.
You have some of the same nanite control that you have before.
Typically the defaults should be just fine.
It should be okay.
And it will look at that object as is.
But again, for heavier surfaces, if you're going to merge them, I recommend using approximate.
Again, we'll get to that one in just a second.
So in this one, we also have material settings.
Since it's making a hybrid, you might want to control the resolution a little bit.
So you don't run to any problems visually.
So that's important to consider.
So simplify, simplifies your texture with resolution options.
Merge makes a two sets of new materials with no material options.
So tries to honor the original.
But you'll end up getting two draw calls with it or multiple, depending on how many materials
you have.
It tries to honor each one.
So again, like I said before, be careful not to have several different objects with
several different materials, because that complexity can make it a little rough if you
decide to migrate them outside of your scene.
You may even convert your scene from a say 5.3 to 5.4.
And you may notice that your blend material no longer exists.
And that will require another for you to run the merge tools again.
And then we have batch.
Now batch is kind of old school.
It's a tries to create an instance for your object.
This one I do not use much.
It doesn't really, I don't find it necessary.
But we do have approximate, which is the new kid on the block.
Now approximate, again, is made for a higher visual fidelity objects.
You'll notice there is no nanite necessarily.
There's a generate a nanite enabled mesh where to generate it.
But you'll notice the settings are a bit different.
They don't have that whole setup.
We had a long and nanite breakdown of things.
There is a material set up here.
So you can set your material capture resolution.
And there's ours a bit debugging if you run into or you suspect you're going to run into
some issues.
But overall, this is pretty straightforward.
And this allows you again to have higher poly objects and merge them to become one draw
call.
That's it with this section.
In the next section, we're going to take a look at HLODs.
Thanks again.